climate experts say the rate of our
reservoirs that are draining here in the
west is extremely alarming lake mead has
seen its lowest level ever now a federal
water shortage on the colorado river is
expected to be announced today hector
mejia is live explaining how this could
impact us here in the valley good
morning hector
hey there's sherry good morning world
it's going to catch up to us at some
point the bureau of reclamation is
holding this press conference this
afternoon to discuss the current and
future drought conditions over at lake
mead we are told this specific
announcement is not expected to impact
us here locally at least not yet farmers
in central arizona however are expecting
hard cutbacks triggered by the
announcement
lake mead still the nation's largest
reservoir has sunk to its lowest level
ever southern nevada gets about 90
percent of its water supply from the
colorado river which serves about 40
million people across seven western
states including us here in nevada in
the year 2000 the water came up to the
top of hoover dam during the mega
drought the lake dropped 140 feet a nasa
satellite is documenting the loss of
water stored in the mountains reservoirs
and even the underground aquifers
jt williams recently described to cbs
this morning what they found out
so these are some images that we've
taken from april 2010 2015 and 2021
showing this steady drying progression
of water in the west
given how severe this drought is and how
long term how long would it take to
recover from something like this we
would need a solid decade of really wet
years which is probably just not going
to happen
you just heard of a solid decade and
williams says what the west needs more
than anything is snow
snowpack in the mountains melts through
the summer and flows into the reservoir
so we'll be covering that announcement
later on today and let you know what
happens here on eight news now reporting
live hector mejia 8 news now back to you
guys